and then you can get started
okay i'm ready to start
perfect okay just started the recording
so give it a few and then
you can go ahead
around there's somebody talking outside
no problem
okay
hello and welcome to my webinar on
anatomy of a nucleic acid sample
preparation
my name is catherine meckling and i'm a
technology development
molecular workflow scientist for
millipore sigma
milpor sigma is the life science
business of marc
kgaa domsdot germany and operates as
millipore sigma
in the u.s and canada
today's webinar i will outline sample
preparation
through a short introduction before
discussing common methods used by
scientists
i'll be highlighting workflows for
genomic dna isolation
finally i'm excited to introduce you to
a new technology coming soon
from the poor sigma called general e
single spin technology
anatomy is a study of the structure or
internal workings of something after
sample collection there are five key
workflow decisions
a scientist makes in regards to their
sample preparation
the first step is homogenization of the
sample
mechanical disruption by using a pestle
or
b beating is often used for tough
samples such as
animal or plant tissues however samples
like
cells or blood can be pelleted before
lysis
the next step is breaking open the
sample and digesting any unwanted
biomolecules
through that lysis step for nucleic acid
sample preparations
typically a lysis buffer is added that
will assist with
breaking into the cells proteases like
the ubiquitous
protein ace k are used to digest the
proteins that can degrade the nucleic
acid
optionally if assessing for dna
sometimes an incubation of rnas is
performed or if rna
rna is assessed a dnase is used
purification is the choice of method for
separating and isolating the biomolecule
of interest
there are several ways of performing
this process and i will dive into some
of the more common workflows later in
this presentation
modification is the process of making
changes to the nucleic acid
that allows for the final step which is
assessment
there are now methods where scientists
will amplify their nucleic acid
by pcr directly after lysis however
however for unbiased assessment
uh results from up here purification
step
is still required
most scientists group lysis and
purification together for sample
preparation
as many off-the-shelf products exist to
address these needs
however before i go deeper into the
different methods of purification
it is important to think about some of
the key pain points
about sample preparation that can impact
downstream sample modification and
assessment
the two key drivers for downstream
failure is poor quality and poor yield
this is due to inherent variability
within individual samples
as well as variability across the
different sample types
typically optimization is required from
the end user in order to validate for
their sample type
additionally incomplete lysis can be
a driver to help reduce to not help but
to cause those reduced yields
nucleic acids degrade over time and that
could potentially lead to reduced
fragment length
and also impact those overall yields
additionally you want to be careful of
those carryover
process contaminants from sample
preparation such as binding salts and
organic solvents
that can have detrimental impacts on
downstream processes
and it is important to be mindful of
these factors
one of the oldest techniques still used
by scientists today for nucleic acid
purification
is phase separation and cleanup this is
commonly called
phenyl chloroform isolation the nucleic
acids separate
due to preferences of a hydrophilic
environment
of the aqueous phase compared to that of
the organic solvent
guanidinium thiocyanate a k-tropic agent
is added to the organic phase to aid in
the denaturation of proteins such as
those that strongly buy nucleic acids
or those that degrade rna under acidic
conditions
such as between phs 4 and 6
dna partitions into the organic phase
while rna remains in the aqueous phase
under neutral conditions such as those
between 7 and 8
both dna and rna will partition into the
aqueous phase
that aqueous phase is then collected and
followed by a
ethanol or isopropanol precipitation
to clean up the organic solvents used to
isolate the nucleic acids
from the sample lysate these organic
solvents can also have
downstream impact the downstream
applications and it's kind of strange to
use organic solvents to clean up organic
solvents
the nucleic acid is finally crashed in a
pellet using a salt and washed multiple
times with organic solvents
the ethanol or isopropanol before
re-spending in a
storage buffer
one of the most common methods for
nucleic acid isolation
is using silica spin columns this is
widely used
out of convenience where commercially
available kits can be performed
safely without a fume hood the silica
membrane is positively charged
and therefore easily bind the negatively
charged nucleic acids
again katropic salts assist with
denaturing of the proteins
from the nucleic acid and also assist in
the binding steps to the membrane
before the sample was washed with an
ethanol solution and eluded in a final
storage buffer
and so began the age of bind wash loot
another common method is using magnetic
beads
these are very similar to the silica
combs
and silica magnetic beads are positively
charged and therefore
again easily bind those negatively
charged nucleic acids
again chaotropic salts are used to
assist in denaturing the proteins from
the nucleic acid
and assist in the bead binding steps
before the sample is washed with an
ethanol solution
and finally eluded in a storage buffer
this process is widely adopted due to
its ease to be automated
over silica spin columns thus making it
popular with high throughput labs
i hope by now you've noticed a pattern
where
if it is either phase separation and
cleanup silicon
magnetic beads or silk spin columns the
process can be tedious
with binding and washing of the nucleic
acid
tube handling can be prone to human
error and these methods typically run
the
risk of cross-contamination yet what if
those bind and wash steps
could be eliminated from the workflow
and now i get to introduce you to
the general e single spin technology
where the nucleic acid is purified in a
single spin
this is eliminating all of the binding
wash steps resulting in reduced
tube handling and a safer and more
efficient
way of handling your sample
you may be thinking you cannot just
eliminate the bind and wash steps
however by using a negative
chromatography method
it is possible instead of binding the
nucleic acid and running the risk of
insufficient binding or non-specific
binding of your sample
negative chromatography uses size
exclusion to
fractionate the components of the sample
by size
this eliminates process biases
associated with
binding nucleic acids to a membrane or
to a bead
larger biomolecules like nucleic acid
flow more readily through a resin bed
while smaller contaminants
are absorbed and retained by differing
migration speeds through the resin beads
and take a longer time to make it
through as you can see through this
graphic the nucleic acids bypass the
beads
while the sample contaminants are
small enough to fit within the beads and
are absorbed thus taking a scenic route
clearing the sample and packing the
resin before loading the superdatan
prevents cellular debris from eluding in
the final sample
these workflow changes provide three key
advantages over silica
simplified workflow superior performance
and reduced waste due to eliminating a
lot of the
tube handling steps and of course no
more kaotropic cells
or ethanol
insufficient lysis can be a set up for
failure from the start
that's why we took a more targeted
approach with general
e smartlice protease mixes
these reagents were chosen for two
specific reasons
one their efficiency to work in a
non-chaotropic environment
and two their optimization for their
sample type
for example animal tissues and bacterial
cell culture samples require
totally different lysis strengths using
a sample specific approach
helps cut down on incubation times and
no k tropes in the lysis buffer means
no kaotros in the final sample
additionally preparing the spin column
for purification
can be performed simultaneously to this
step for even more workflow time savings
but let's take a closer look at the
column itself preparing the column for
use is a simple process
a separate collection tube is used to
collect the void volume
from the column and can be reused since
it actually never touches the sample
additionally the cap should be loosened
a quarter of a turn or a cap punching
tool
can be used to prevent prevent a vacuum
from forming within the column
the fir beyond that you need to snap
off the bottom closure so the sample has
a place to go
additionally you need to resuspend the
bead matrix
by a simple vortex step so that they
are resuspended and that they pack more
evenly
during the column preparation step and
after
setting the column the column buffer is
removed and the slam may or may not be
observed due to that lovely
centrifugation step
now you can choose your own workflow you
can simply
load your sample directly into the
column without opening the purification
column
just use the general e single spin cap
puncher device
this helps reduce cross contamination by
keeping the sample contained between
transfer steps while this tool is meant
to work specifically with general e
purification columns
it is not required for purification all
you have to do
is load your sample directly onto the
resin bead after unscrewing the cap
just remember to keep the cap loosened a
quarter turn
if no hole is punched in the cap one
spin
and you're done and now you have a
general e purified
nucleic acid
remember those pesky organic solvents
and kaotropic salts from previous
nucleic acid workflows shown here is an
example
of spectrophotometric data comparison
between
silica based protocols and the general e
single spin workflow
in purple is the sample purified by the
different methods
and blue or teal is the purification
without the sample being added
in red is the sample without any
processed contaminants and in yellow
is the back background or the blank for
this analysis
as you can see in this example the
process contaminants can be observed
from the silica method in the od 230
range
spinning the sample only once has other
advantages
as well bimolecular weight genomic dna
is critical for certain downstream
applications
such as next generation sequencing or
electron microscopy
silica based purification methods rely
on multiple spins that can shear
the nucleic acid shown here is four
replicate samples
purified either using a silica column or
a general e column
as you can see there's more full length
product on the electrophoresis gel
for the general e purified nucleic acids
additionally the smaller fragments that
could
potentially be due to shearing of the
nucleic acids are often included in
yield calculations
and can give a false sense of how much
template is being used in downstream
workflows
without adding processed contaminants to
the sample purification
downstream modifications and assessments
are more reliable
and it makes sense polymerases and
restriction enzymes have preferred
buffers
and salts and do not like organic
solvents
these factors can impact the
thermodynamics of a reaction
shown here is an example of qpcr
of mouse kidney tissue assessing for a
housekeeping gene
from genomic dna isolated by the two
methods
silica or general e single spin basilica
isolated genomic dna
has a higher ct value indicating either
there's inhibition in the reaction or
there's inaccurate quantitation of the
template
being added to the reaction
the e in general e highlights several
eco-friendly
improvements the first of course is that
there's
no more hazardous liquid waste and this
is done by eliminating the binding
and wash steps that have those ethanol
and kaotropic salts
additionally we re-thought about the
packaging
so this has sustainable packaging in
mind where the box in the insert is made
of 70
recyclable content additionally this is
the first product
to have compostable materials used for
packaging and that's what all of our
columns
are packaged in plus since it's a
simplified workflow and there's fewer
steps
there's a higher see savings in
energy costs and you can actually
measure the waste prevention
on how much plastic between the two
workflows
where if i take all the pipette tips all
the tubes used in the workflow
to isolate as well as the column
weight of the column itself if i take
the measurements of
purifying one sample compared to
purifying the other there's a 55 percent
reduction
in plastic weight that is commonly um
costs users for disposal
and here are they
finally there's these key applications
that we are targeting with the
initial launch of this product um it's
being targeted initially for genomic dna
from sample types such as whole blood
cell culture
animal tissue and plant tissue we have
supporting products
as well the cap puncher some ffpe
deparamation solution which is also a
safer
solution since it's commonly used for
xylene which is
very unsafe so this is not a xylene
um deep pyruvation solution so it's a
lot safer to use
we also have a tissue stabilizer and an
rna gel loading buffer
plus you can if you're not isolating
directly from
a lysate if you're just trying to purify
or deplete an impurity from your
sample we also have these cleanup kits
that are also available
and you can use our handy dandy
selection tool here
in order to choose for your cleanup type
we have only just begun but we already
have several products for you to try
these products will be available very
soon in just a couple weeks so
i really hope you get a chance to check
them out
thank you again i hope you enjoyed this
presentation
and i look forward to your questions
okay awesome job uh well we are all set
pretty much from here i'll just do some
quick editing on the
front and back end since there is no
interruptions during your presentation
and then we'll have it ready for the
event next week
okay thank you so much of course any
questions for me before we wrap
up nope that was it thank you
awesome have a good rest of your day
bye-bye thanks bye